und jetzt das heute journal
mit heinz wolf und marietta slomka guten
abend beginnen wir mit einer guten
nachricht die impfungen in den
pflegeheimen zeigen offenbar wirkung
die faz hat dazu große betreiber wie
caritas oder johanniter befragt und
demnach ist die zahl der bewohner die an
corona schwer erkranken oder gaffer
sterben bereits stark zurückgegangen
auch die nach altersgruppen
aufgeschlüsselten statistiken des rk ii
zeigen in diese richtung
umso wünschenswerter wäre es natürlich
dass das verenden vorhandener dosen
insgesamt schneller voranschreitet auch
in anderen impf gruppen was inzwischen
eine debatte darüber ausgelöst hat warum
von astrazeneca impfstoff so viele dosen
noch ungenutzt im kühlfach liegen dazu
gleich noch ein gespräch mit dem
vorsitzenden der ständigen
impfkommission doch erstmal der bericht
von stefan deges die diskussion um den
impfstoff von astrazeneca ist auch hier
angekommen in der schlange vor dem
impfzentrum in wiesbaden
ja hat mich schon verunsichert muss ich
sagen ist dafür in schutz
wie man hört deutlich höher ist mit
biontech und ich habe sehr sehr viele
frisch menschen die kontakt auch mit
risikopatienten
und ja da möchte glaube ich jeder
einfach den impfstoff haben der am
bekämpfen dabei seien die zweifel am
astra zeneca stoff unbegründet betont
ärger vieler heute nochmals und zitiert
eine schottische studie dort senkte der
impfstoff die quote der
krankenhauseinweisungen um 94 prozent
gegen schwere krankheitsverläufe schützt
der impfstoff also sehr gut bei milderen
krankheitsverläufen ist die wirksamkeit
etwas geringer dieser impfstoff ist
wirklich sehr sehr wirksam und dass der
impfstoff von manchen nicht angenommen
wird das hören wir das ist einfach
fachlich sachlich nicht gerechtfertigt
dennoch hat der impfstoff ein schlechtes
image und die politik sucht dafür schon
nach schuldigen
wir haben im stoff noch und nöcher als
antrat zenica im stoff in großbritannien
ein renner
warum ist das bei uns so diskreditiert
worden tatsächlich gab es mehrere
kommunikationspannen und probleme rund
um astrazeneca auch durch das
unternehmen selbst
es gab ja aus den frühen klinischen
studien gab es ein parallel wirkungs
meldungen wie sich nachher nicht
bestätigt haben sie sozusagen in der
presse auftauchten
dann gab es halt relativ verwirrende
publikationen die schwer zu kodieren war
für auch für fachjournalisten wie uns
also wissenschaftler alliston und
dadurch ist glaube ich auch sondern die
menge lage entstanden jetzt sagen wir
vertrauen in den impfstoffen fördern hat
es liegt aber auch an der debatte über
den stoff die ständige impfkommission
empfiehlt astrazeneca nur für unter
65-jährige und ende januar berichtete
das handelsblatt vertreter der
bundesregierung würden die wirksamkeit
des impfstoffes in frage stellen
der zweifel war gesät obwohl das vakzin
foto vitt schützt wir wissen aus der
psychologischen forschung dass zum
beispiel menschen bei der
impfentscheidung sehr schnell
verunsichert werden sie können durch
falschinformationen oder
fehlinformationen wer schnell ihre
intention aber ich möchte mich impfen
lassen
die kann sinken
mit den auswirkungen haben sie nun vor
allem in den impfzentren wie hier in
wiesbaden zu kämpfen uns darüber wollen
wir mit dem vorsitzenden der ständigen
impfkommission stiko sprechen professor
thomas mertens guten abend herr
professor mertens wer sieht ihn per
skype zugeschaltet
guten tag herr professor märz ist die
frage im raum warum entwickelt sich
dieses astra zenica so etwas zum
ladenhüter milde gesagt im moment und da
geraten auch sie beziehungsweise die
stiko in den foren den fokus bereuen sie
es im nachhinein dass sie speziell diese
einschränkung gemacht haben diesen
impfstoff nur für die unter 65-jährigen
zu empfehlen
ja das hat mit bereuen nichts zu tun wir
hatten die daten die wir hatten und
haben auf der basis dieser daten diese
empfehlung gegeben aber wir haben die
den impfstoff kritisiert sondern wir
haben dort kritisiert dass die datenlage
eben für die altersgruppe über 65 nicht
gut oder nicht ausreichend war
das muss man schon auseinanderhalten
ansonsten ist der impfstoff sehr gut und
war schon gut und wird durch jetzt hinzu
kommen die neue daten auch noch besser
in der einschätzung so dass es endlich
die frage wer zu beantworten dass das
ganze ist einfach ja irgendwie schlecht
gelaufen
dazu kommen wir gleich noch auch zu den
neuen daten aber als nun auch sie die
stiko empfehlung ausgegeben hat da gab
es ja auch andere empfehlungen also zum
beispiel von der europäischen von der
europäischen arzneimittelagentur ema und
von der whu und die haben diese
einschränkungen nicht gemacht so aber
hatte astrazeneca ich von anfang an so
einen makel ist nicht sicher genug oder
nicht gut genug für die alten und jetzt
denn wenn auch nicht los also die leute
mit denen ich spreche die sprechen
eigentlich immer von den berühmten 70%
schutzwirkung und weniger von dem alters
könnte außerdem muss man sagen dass die
immer ja zwar die zulassung als
unbeschränkt gemacht hat aber selbst in
ihrer zulassung hineingeschrieben war
dass die daten bei den über 55-jährigen
eigentlich nicht ausreichend sind
jetzt haben aber inzwischen eine art
feldstudie in schottland zum beispiel
dass es werden hunderttausende mio
nun sind inzwischen mit diesem impfstoff
versorgt und da zeigt sich sie an es
scheint doch auch bei den älteren auch
bei über 80 jährigen wirklich enorme
wirkung zu haben und vor allem vor
schweren krankheiten und tod zu schützen
müsste man da nicht auch sagen gut jetzt
ändern wir das für deutschland auch und
und öffnen den impfstoff auch für die
älteren
das ist möglich und das werden wir auch
tun wir haben uns schon die daten sehr
genau angeguckt aus schottland es gibt
allerdings bei diesen daten die april
emi leer sind und die auch nur den
zustand nach einer entführung
beschreiben und die beobachtung sagt
geradezu erst nach circa ist maximal 34
tage nach dieser ersten entwurf also
zusammengefasst es gibt zu dieser studie
noch einiges zu fragen und das haben wir
auch schon direkt getan und bei der
erste autor ihn angefragt ob sie uns
dann noch nachhilfe geben können und
dass dann noch schnell auf jetzt an ist
geschrieben worden und jetzt wollen wir
mal gucken was wir verantworten kriegen
eine andere frage ist ob man den
impfstoff ähnlich wie die briten das
machen oder auch bei anderen impfstoffen
ob man da erst mal nicht direkt dosen
zurückhält um auf jeden fall diesen
patienten eine zweite impfung geben zu
können sondern erstmal alles raushaut
also allen erstmal eine erste impfung
gibt und es dann zeitlich gegebenenfalls
auch streckt würden sie das in der
jetzigen lage sie sind ja auch virologe
also kennen sie auch mit impfstoffen und
viren und wirkungen wirklich gut aus
wenn sie das empfehlen
also auch da ist es so wir müssen
eigentlich auf daten warten die in den
längeren beobachtungszeitraum haben
aber ich hätte das womöglich gerade bei
dem astra zeneca impfstoff dass man sich
tatsächlich dazu etwas noch längere
intervalle entscheiden können
bei dem brand im stoff sind die daten
jetzt auch die aus schottland eigentlich
nicht dazu geeignet unbedingt diese
entscheidung jetzt zu treffen aber wir
müssen verstehen wir wollen die daten in
einer form publiziert wird die sozusagen
eine entscheidung wirklich wirklich das
ist auch gar nicht dass wir besonders
verstockt sind sondern es einfach die
aufgabe sich die daten genauer
anzugucken
ja schon aber in einer
katastrophensituation geht ja vielleicht
manchmal auch schnelligkeit vor super
super genauigkeit
andere länder trauen sich das ja auch da
etwas schneller und beherzter sozusagen
voranzuschreiten dieser wir werden das
genau prüfen und es wird ja auch sehr
bald zu einer neuen aktualisierten
empfehlung kommen
allein schon deshalb weil er dann der
johnson & johnson starb wahrscheinlich
zugelassen sein wird und im rahmen
dieser aktualisierung wird man
gegebenenfalls anpassungen auch dieser
dieses punktes vorleben dass auf jeden
fall schon mal eine interessante
neuigkeit herr professor merkens danke
für das gespräch
das interview haben wir aufgezeichnet
solange das mit dem impfen jedenfalls so
schleppend geht während sich das virus
gleichzeitig verstärkung geholt hat
stichwort mutanten sind weitere
öffnungen zumindest viele virologen und
klinikärzte warnen ja sogar davor die
politik hat aber bereits die erwartung
geweckt dass jetzt bald mal gute ist mit
dem shutdown
da wird oft argumentiert die bürger
wollten dass die menschen eher trüben
keine einschränkungen mehr
aber es gibt dir eigentlich gar nicht
die bürger oder das volk sondern
millionen individuen mit teils sehr
unterschiedlichen meinungen im neuen
politbarometer jedenfalls ist immer noch
eine breite mehrheit mit den aktuell
geltenden anti corona maßnahmen
einverstanden oder plädiert sogar für
verschärfungen
allerdings ist der anteil derer die die
maßnahmen für übertrieben halten
deutlich gestiegen auf 23 prozent
differenziert ist auch das meinungsbild
bei der frage nach lockerungen die
zahlen dazu gibt es ausführlich am ende
unserer sendung wir wenden uns jetzt
erstmal noch dem thema schnelltests zu
sind sie die neue wunderwaffe
was können sie für öffnungs strategien
leisten der frage ist anna maria schuck
nachgekommen spucken gurgeln oder
abstreichen schnelltests gelten neben
impfungen als schlüssel in der pandemie
bekämpfung
testen allein reicht nicht sagen
marburger wissenschaftler
sie fordern einen schnelltest strategie
die gleichzeitig öffnungen ermöglicht
und zwar sofort
[Musik]
unabhängig vom virus und unabhängig vom
typ des virus ist diese diese ausbrüche
einfangen
in ihrem konzept entwerfen sie eine
shutdown alternative
zentrales instrument regelmäßige corona
schnelltests gepaart mit einer digitalen
grenzübergreifenden infrastruktur in der
praxis könnte eine test app zum einsatz
kommen erste prototypen gibt es bereits
etwa aus österreich und so könnte sie
funktionieren
nachdem ich mich registriert habe wertet
die app über die handykamera ein
schnelltest aus erkennt ob eher positiv
oder negativ ist und er stellt einen
individuellen zeitlich begrenzten qr
code mit dem könnte ich mich dann als
negativ getestet ausweisen etwa beim
friseur oder an der kinokasse raus aus
dem schatten und mit test und das bei
einer sieben tage incidents deutlich
über 50 geht das überhaupt frage an
einen der das infektionsgeschehen von
berufswegen modelliert
die kurze antwort ist ja die tatsache
dass die infektionszahlen nicht weiter
herunter gehen muss daran liegen dass
die neue virus mutation sich ausbreitet
und da könnte man jetzt durch noch
stärkere restriktionen gegen steuern
aber die andere möglichkeit ist halt
dass wir mit den schnellschuss versuchen
ein gutes regime zu schaffen und wir
sehen in den simulationen auch dass das
sehr gut funktionieren könnte und das
obwohl antigen schnelltests weniger
genau sind und auch zu falschen
negativen ergebnissen kommen können
mal angenommen wir bleiben jetzt alle im
lok da und wie wir jetzt sind und dann
kommt der neue virus dann würde es
eigentlich eine dritte welle geben
aber wenn auch nur zehn prozent der
bevölkerung einmal pro woche durch so
ein schnelltest getestet würden würde
das schon ausreichen um das zu
unterdrücken
das stimmt dann natürlich nicht mehr
wenn wir eröffnen also wenn beim öffnen
müssen wir mehr machen aber das kann
insgesamt große fehlerquoten haben und
funktioniert immer noch entscheiden
bleibt aber was jeder einzelne mit dem
testergebnis macht sagt biophysiker
jonas binding wie sie beim frei testen
die gefahr dass die leute sorglos werden
weil sie es nicht gut genug erklärt
bekommen die leute müssen wissen dass
ein test jeder test auch falsch liegen
kann und deshalb andere maßnahmen
hygienemaßnahmen weiter eingehalten
werden müssen solange ein negativer
schnelltest nicht als freifahrtschein
begriffen wird und sich weiterhin jeder
positiv getestete isoliert können
schnelltests ein instrument für
öffnungen sein da sind sich alle drei
einig
[Musik]
klar ist jedenfalls auch dass jeder
weitere tag das statt da uns nicht nur
nerven sondern auch viel viel geld
kostet und mit dem thema gesetzliche
nachrichten weiter hand der bundestag
hat weitere hilfen beschlossen für
bedürftige familien und unternehmen
geringverdiener und sozialhilfeempfänger
sollen einmalig 150 euro bekommen das
gleiche erhalten familien pro kind in
gaststätten gilt auf speisen bis ende
2022 der vergünstigte mehrwertsteuersatz
von sieben prozent und unternehmen
sollen verluste steuerlich mit gewinnen
aus dem vorjahr verrechnen können
die linke hat ihren parteitag begonnen
kroner bedingt online bei dem
zweitägigen delegiertentreffen wird auch
ein wechsel an der parteispitze auf den
weg gebracht nach fast neun jahren als
vorsitzende wird katja kipping nach
ihrer abschiedsrede heute bei der wahl
morgen nicht erneut kandidieren
auch der co vorsitzende bernd riexinger
tritt nicht wieder an
kandidatinnen für die nachfolge sind
janine wissler und susann heilig weil so
der csu politiker georg nüßlein hat zu
den korruptionsermittlungen gegen ihn
über seinen anwalt erklärt er halte die
vorwürfe für nicht begründet
bis zu einer klärung wolle er sein amt
als stellvertretender vorsitzender der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion ruhen lassen
gestern hatte der bundestag seine
immunität aufgehoben und die
staatsanwaltschaft umfangreiche
durchsuchungen durchgeführt der verdacht
bestechlichkeit im zusammenhang mit von
ihm vermittelten atemschutzmasken
mit einer groß angelegten razzia ist die
polizei in thüringen sachsen anhalt und
hessen gegen einen mutmaßlich
kriminelles neonazi netzwerk vorgegangen
bei durchsuchungen von 27 wohnungen und
geschäftsräumen fanden die beamten nach
angaben des landeskriminalamtes
thüringen unter anderem rund 120.000
euro bargeld und schusswaffen
zehn personen wurden festgenommen das
us-militär hat auf befehl von präsident
biden stellungen einer pro- iranischen
miliz im osten syriens angegriffen
bei den luftschlägen soll nach angaben
syrischer aktivisten 22 kämpfer getötet
worden sein
die massnahmen sind laut
us-verteidigungsminister osten eine
antwort auf raketenangriffe auf
einrichtungen der usa und ihrer
verbündeten im irak vergangene woche war
ein von der internationalen
militärkoalition genutzter luftwaffen
stützpunkt angegriffen worden
manchmal ist es ja auch eine sensation
wenn etwas bestätigt wird was man
eigentlich schon wusste als der im exil
lebende saudische journalist cascioli
bei einem termin in der saudischen
botschaft in istanbul getötet wurde
und zwar auf grausliche art da stand
sofort der verdacht im raum dass das
saudische königshaus dahinter stand
speziell der kronprinz nur offizielle
belege dass er persönlich die aktion
angeordnet hatte fanden sich und das
weiße haus unter donald trump sah keinen
anlass zu kritik an der königsfamilie
den man sich eng verbunden fühlt nun
aber wurden in washington berichte des
amerikanischen geheimdienstes
veröffentlicht die eindeutig den prinzen
beschuldigen kastriert gerade eben
empört zurückgewiesen hat aus
versteckten eines traums erleichtert
reagiert die verlobte von jamal karsli
gerechtigkeit für jamal twittert sie im
oktober 2018 war der saudische
journalist georgy wohl von einem
spezialkommando getötet worden seine
leiche wurde nie gefunden
immer war angenommen worden der
saudische kronprinz könnte für die
operation verantwortlich sein
das bestätigt nun ein bericht der us
geheimdienste mohammed bin salman soll
entführung oder tötung hobbys
genehmigt haben der kritische journalist
eine gefahr für das königreich
darstellte der bisherige präsident trump
hielt den bericht unter verschluss
waffengeschäfte hatten priorität er
unterstützte das königshaus weiterhin
der neue präsident joe biden macht es
anders einreisebeschränkungen werden nun
gegen 76 saudis verhängt vertraute des
prinzen mit sanktionen belegt es ist ein
neuer umgang der usa mit dem verbündeten
saudi arabien penissen in washington und
damit auch definitiv kein zufall dass
die geheimdienste rechte erst jetzt
veröffentlicht werden dazu braucht es
dann schon den wechsel im weißen haus
ja das ist ja das hat damit zu tun
natürlich gab es die beweise schon
länger aber donald trump waren ganz
offenbar die wirtschafts deals und die
waffengeschäfte wichtiger und das ist
hier so eine art paradigmenwechsel jetzt
in neue präsident sagt menschenrechte
gehen vor diesen wirtschafts geschäften
die man da macht er hat ja vor einigen
wochen auch schon die waffengeschäfte
mit saudi arabien eingefroren zurzeit
nun sind eine reihe von personen eben
auf ich sag mal schwarzen listen was
einreise angebt deren einkommen oder
konten werden eingefroren wenn sie
gelder in den usa haben
aber und da sagen kritiker das ist
natürlich höchst ins konsequent der
grund prinz selber ist nicht ziel dieser
sanktionen warum eigentlich nicht
aber ich glaube da steckt ein bisschen
der zwiespalt für die administration
dahinter man stempelt jetzt diesen
kronprinzen sehr klar zum auftraggeber
für einen mord und will ihn isolieren
der präsident hat darauf bestanden dass
er diese woche beim gespräch mit dem
könig nicht dabei gewesen ist beim
telefongespräch mal will auch klar
machen wer sich mit ihm ein lässt der
muss damit rechnen ins visier der usa zu
kommen
ob dahinter die naive hoffnung steckt
dass sich die thronfolge noch einmal
ändert oder ob man vielleicht einfach
nur ganz genau weiß wenn der könig
sterben würde dann hätte man mit bin
salman in zukunft als könig zu tun
man danke schonmal für diese
einschätzung direkt aus washington
interessant wird auch sein wie sich die
regierung beiden zum thema afghanistan
positioniert
vor einem jahr hatte die trump regierung
mit den taliban ein abkommen
unterzeichnet in dem festgelegt wurde
dass die us truppen bis mai das land
verlassen
im gegenzug sollten die taliban sicher
friedensgespräche mit der regierung in
kabul einlassen
doch diese verhandlungen ziehen sich
dahin ohne sichtbare fortschritte
und so sieht es im moment nicht nach
einem baldigen abzug der us-truppen aus
auch die bundeswehr bleibt vorerst dort
das mandat wurde ja gerade erst
verlängert heute war die
bundesverteidigungsministerium auf
truppenbesuch annegret kramp karrenbauer
besuchte das einsatzkontingent in masar
i scharif
anlass für unsere reporterin katrin
eigendorf auf die lage in afghanistan zu
blicken wie steht es um das land sie
sind jung sie sind unerfahren und sie
haben sich für einen der gefährlichsten
jobs in ihrem land entschieden soldat
beim afghanischen militär auf dem
stützpunkt bachmann lernen sie die
grundlagen eine ausbildung bei der die
bundeswehr im norden afghanistans seit
fünf jahren unterstützt deutsche
soldaten schulen in masar i scharif
führungskräfte sie beraten die spitze
der armee noch einmal soll die mission
jetzt verlängert werden
bei einem spontanen truppenbesuch heute
in masar i scharif betonte
verteidigungsministerin kramp
karrenbauer deutschland wollen
afghanistan weiter unterstützen
ziel sei jedoch ein geordneter rückzug
das verteidigungsministerium in kabul
mehr wir erwarten von der
internationalen gemeinschaft und von der
deutschen regierung der sie ihre
unterstützung für die afghanische armee
fortsetzen damit wir gemeinsam die
terrorgruppen in afghanistan und in der
region schlagen und vernichten können
die taliban kontrollieren inzwischen
fast die hälfte des landes marschieren
selbstbewusst auf den straßen auf und
greifen gezielt afghanische
sicherheitskräfte an ihr ziel
afghanistan soll ein islamisches emirat
werden friedensgespräche zwischen ihren
vertretern und der afghanischen
regierung stocken die taliban verlangen
dennoch dass die internationalen truppen
wie mit den usa vor einem jahr
vereinbart im mai abziehen
andernfalls drohen sie mit krieg auch
gegen deutsche soldaten
unsere wirtschaft an die nato und ihre
mitglieder ist wenn sie ihre kinder in
frieden aufwachsen lassen wollen wenn
sie ihre länder in frieden säen wollen
dann sollten sie unser land verlassen
und ihre besatzung alleine werden
afghanistans sicherheitskräfte nach
meinung internationaler experten den
vormarsch der taliban nicht stoppen
können und die regierung droht das land
könne künftig wieder zum rückzugsgebiet
für internationale terroristen werden
wir brauchen ihre unterstützung wir
benötigen waffen auch weitere
unterstützung bei der ausbildung im
training aber auch dabei militärische
operationen und angriffe durchzuführen
das ist jetzt extrem wichtig abziehen
oder bleiben eine wichtige entscheidung
die die nato und ihre verbündeten
treffen müssen vorläufig bleiben wird
nicht reichen
eine ausführliche reportage aus
afghanistan finden sie in unserer
zdfmediathek bei dokus und reportagen
unter dem titel come back der taliban
wer hat die macht in afghanistan und
jetzt macht heinz nochmal weiter
zunächst mit wirtschaft in pandemie
zeiten zu den instrumenten die die
wirtschaftlichen auswirkungen der korona
pandemie auf dem arbeitsmarkt abfedern
sollen gehört die kurzarbeit ein
instrument das milliarden kostet wie
viele milliarden franken
dazu gibt es neuigkeiten ja tatsächlich
ist das hochgelobte kurzarbeitergeld
eine teure angelegenheit vor allem wenn
es über einen längeren zeitraum
eingesetzt werden muss und wenn es
durchschnittlich mehr menschen in
anspruch nehmen als eigentlich gedacht
und so musste die bundesagentur für
arbeit schon früh im jahr einen ersten
kassensturz machen
heraus kam dass die ursprünglich
eingeplanten sechs milliarden euro
bereits im märz aufgebraucht sein werden
weswegen die bundesagentur für arbeit
für das kurzarbeitergeld inzwischen
weitere 6,3 milliarden euro im etat
veranschlagt quasi eine verdopplung
20.20 kostete die agentur die kurzarbeit
sogar über 22 milliarden euro
insbesondere im letzten jahr war das ein
noch nie dagewesener kraftakt in der
spitze haben wir an einem tag mehr
kurzarbeitergeld ausgezahlt als im
gesamten jahr 2019 sagte heute die
finanzchefin der arbeitsagentur
die folge die noch vor corinna üppigen
milliardenschweren rücklagen der agentur
werden zum jahresende komplett
aufgezehrt sein und bereits jetzt wird
darüber spekuliert ob der
bundesfinanzminister einen
nachtragshaushalt auflegen muss und
spekuliert wird natürlich auch hier an
der börse warum bloß tut sich der dax in
dieser woche so schwer anderthalb
prozent verliert das kursbarometer
unterm strich sei die furcht vor einer
steigenden inflation sagen die börsianer
und dennoch ist das aktienbarometer auch
weiterhin nur zweieinhalb prozent von
seinem allzeithoch entfernt
frank wittmann vielen dank bei der
nordischen ski wm in oberstdorf haben
die deutschen skispringerinnen im
mannschafts wettbewerb nur platz fünf
belegt der rückstand des
titelverteidigers auf die protest
trainer gross die goldmedaille ging an
das team aus österreich silber an
slowenien und bronze an norwegen
auch die deutschen männer verpassten in
der nordischen kombination die
medaillenränge allerdings denkbar knapp
eric frenzel fehlten am ende weniger als
sechs sekunden und er musste sich mit
dem undankbaren vierten platz zufrieden
geben
gold ging an den norweger magnus reber
vor dem findel carola und auch bronze
gewann ein norweger jens lorenz bösch co
das ist ein neues zdf-politbarometer
gibt habe ich am anfang der sendung hier
schon angesprochen und jetzt in aller
ausführlichkeit präsentiert von matthias
fornoff
guten abend willkommen zum
politbarometer frühling im februar das
hat in den letzten tagen die stimmung
etwas aufgehellt
eigentlich aber herrscht pandemie blues
die unzufriedenheit mit dem
krisenmanagement wächst vor allem
gesundheitsminister sparen steht in der
kritik
die schleppende impfkampagne eine
vorerst gescheiterte schnelltest
offensive nicht nur für den
koalitionspartner spd sind das zu viele
ankündigungen und so wenig taten die
bürger wollen perspektiven sehen und
immer mehr menschen sehnen sich nach
lockerungen dass die geltenden corona
maßnahmen übertrieben sind das denkt
inzwischen fast jeder vierte im
vergleich zur letzten umfrage ein plus
von 9 prozentpunkten für mehr als die
hälfte sind die maßnahmen weiter gerade
richtig
18 prozent meinen sie müssten härter
ausfallen dass grundschulen in den
meisten bundesländern jetzt geöffnet
sind finden mehr als vier von zehn
befragten richtig und mehr als ein
viertel wäre sogar dafür gewesen alle
schulen zu öffnen
den beschluss die impfung der lehrer und
erzieher vorzuziehen befürworten fast 90
prozent
lockerungen bei dem corona maßnahmen die
wünschen sich 56 prozent
am lautesten ist dieser ruf im lager von
afd und fdp aber auch bei den anhängern
der union und der linken ist man
mehrheitlich dafür
die spd anhänger sind gespalten und die
anhänger der grünen mehrheitlich gegen
lockerungen wo rund jeder fünfte findet
dass es in jedem fall lockerungen geben
soll
also auch wenn die infektionszahlen
wieder stark ansteigen
35 prozent wollen sie dann lieber nicht
der wunsch nach etwas mehr normalität
ist groß und auf dem weg dahin gibt es
für die deutschen einen bereich der ganz
klar oberste priorität hat bitte zuerst
läden und geschäfte öffnen dafür gibt es
mit 40 prozent die größte zustimmung
mit abstand folgen die kontakte sport
kultur und freizeitmöglichkeiten sowie
restaurants
die stimmung im land ändert sich es gibt
zwar weiter großen rückhalt für das
handeln der regierung
aber nicht mehr uneingeschränkt schauen
wir auf die projektion
wenn schon am nächsten sonntag
bundestagswahl wäre
dann könnten cdu/csu mit 35 prozent
rechnen
- 2 der schlechteste wert seit april
letzten jahres spd 16
hf g10 die fdp 7 prozent alle plus 1 die
linke unverändert 7 prozent und die
grünen 19 prozent minus 1 damit gebe es
weiter eine mehrheit für schwarz grün
und schwarz rot bei der union ist noch
offen wer ins rennen geht ums kanzleramt
die befragten haben da eine klare
präferenz
53 prozent sind sich sicher
markus söder wäre geeignet als
bundeskanzler 37 prozent sehen das
anders
bei armin laschet umgedrehte
verhältnisse nur 28 prozent könnten sich
ihn im amt vorstellen
57% nicht bei den anhängern der union
finden übrigens sogar 74 prozent dass
söder als kanzler geeignet wäre
bei laschet sind es 36 prozent in
unseren top ten verlieren alle
politikerinnen und politiker an ansehen
am schwersten trifft es die an den
entscheidungs hebeln hier die bewertung
nach sympathie und leistung auf der
skala von +5 bis -5 auf platz 10
friedrich merz minus 0,3 peter altmaier
0,5 deutlich schlechter platz acht für
annalena baerbock 0,7 davor armin
laschet 0,7 jens spahn 0,8 stark
verschlechtert platz fünf für robert
habeck 0,9 dann heiko maas 0,9 auf platz
3 olaf scholz 1,1 platz 2 markus söder
1,2 und an der spitze angela merkel 2,1
alle drei stark verschlechtert
die unzufriedenheit mit der politik
sicher auch spiegel der gesamtsituation
das auftreten der virus mutationen
verunsichert der cs shutdown geht an die
nerven
zumal fast zwei drittel der befragten
davon ausgehen dass es auch zu einer
dritten infektionswelle kommen wird
hoffnung machen immerhin die
schnelltests 59 prozent meinen die
durchführung vieler schnelltests kann
stark helfen die korona krise in den
griff zu bekommen
40 prozent glauben das nicht am
kommenden mittwoch beraten bund und
länder wieder dabei soll es auch um die
ausweitung der schnelltests gehen ob es
den von vielen ersehnten fahrplan für
lockerungen gibt ist offen
das war unser bericht über die stimmung
im land die grafiken und alle
informationen zu unseren umfragen finden
sie wie immer im zdf text ab seite 165
in der zdf- heute- app und auf zdf
heute.de wie die repräsentativen
umfragen der forschungsgruppe wahlen
zustande kommen
informationen zur methodik und zu den
qualitätsstandards finden sie unter
politbarometer punkt zdf.de vielen dank
für ihr interesse
das nächste bundesweite politbarometer
gibt es dann am 26 märz und schon
kommende woche am fünften märz gibt es
eine extra ausgabe zu den anstehenden
wahlen in rheinland pfalz und baden
württemberg nach dem wetter heute mit
eisbär geht es hier weiter mit der heute
show mit oliver welke ihnen noch einen
entspannten abend auch wieder sehen
guten abend meine damen und herren
morgen ist welttag des eisbären wie sich
das klima am nordpol ändert märkte ja
schon länger er findet weniger fressen
muss daher größere gebiete bejagen und
dennoch länger fasten wenn das eis taut
und taut weil neben der luft auch das
wasser wärmer wird
während weißes eis das sonnenlicht
reflektiert nimmt das dunkle eisfreie
meerwasser die sonnenwärme auf wird noch
wärmer beschleunigt den eissport
warmwasser ströme unter dem grönlandeis
lecken es von unten weg so geschwächt
brechen schon mal riesige eisstücke ab
im jahr 2100 wird der ice wäre
wahrscheinlich nur noch in der
nördlichsten arktis überlegen können es
sei denn wir menschen bremsen die
temperatur erhöhen drastisch
dann würden auch wetterkapriolen wie in
diesem februar für extreme frost zum
frühsommer in nur sieben tagen seltener
heute nacht fällt in süddeutschland
regen sonst ist es mal mehr mal weniger
stark bewölkt bei temperaturen von plus
4 bis minus zwei grad und morgen halten
sich dichtere wolken zwischen der
lüneburger heide und dem erzgebirge
sonst scheint häufig die sonne bei
höchstwerten zwischen 4 und 12 grad und
in den nächsten tagen beschränken sich
die dichteren wolken auf norddeutschland
sonst zeigt sich häufig die sonne und
von südwesten wird es von tag zu tag
etwas milder
schönes wochenende